do you have a dream get off your ass and
make that [ __ ] happen
[Music]
welcome to another episode of rhythm
with Griffin and this is another dope
intro song made by Brad Kyle who is
mundo and ladies and gentlemen I want to
welcome to the show another special
guest from workaholics the first
director that ever directed me mr. Kyle
nuna check right here's your body
welcome to rippln Wicker thank you do
you like this I like it I mean is it an
amazing quality it's got it's got good
production yeah Kyle yeah I did a good
job yes you did Kyle you did a great job
I mean that's cool that sets the tone in
like a good way to it's like yeah right
we set the tone but anyways we might get
real you know we could have started
freestyle rapping for all we know you
know no I don't think we should well it
is good to see you my friend
um I'm so glad you came on and it's like
I haven't seen you since Montreal see
you know I was at he's the director of a
very good Adam Sandler Netflix movie
called murder mystery which is coming
out when well right now the word on the
street is summer okay well it's gonna be
on the summer but they might pull it up
Netflix has been known to do that before
oh so I don't know could it could be
there sooner than later I'm not sure
those guys are wild well I hope so it
was like it worked out great I mean I
remember you randomly hit me up like hey
I got this thing I didn't you didn't
really you weren't even clear about it
no no you just I just you know there's a
lot of levels there's a lot of things
that can you know I feel like part of
the direct like asking for something
like that is managing expectations to
being like
a well if I told you early early then
it's like you could be hanging on for a
while thinking about it and it's like I
don't want to put that type of the
pressure yeah expectation like let the
pressure be the moment when we shoot you
know what I mean
well you also were not on you were all
rocky ground with me
is that right yes because you hit me up
to do a scene in what was it the the
boys movie was it was all game over man
right yes so Kyle hits me he's like hey
I remember you call you go hey man I got
a heart be in this movie and I'm like
I'm ready to go and you go well hold on
a second yeah then I had to make sure it
measures your expectations
let me tell you what this part is so you
wanted me to come on and get my ass
eaten this is the big thing you said
it's funny your scene in the movie that
was your sales pitch yeah well it is
it's hilarious that why didn't you do it
I don't know really
my you didn't want us eating on screen
well not really so you call it all you
call old Montez to get his ass also game
over man represents me taking a step
back from acting I'll hear weak
pretentious piece of [ __ ] how dare you
yes I thought that this the character's
name was husky hostage oh okay first of
all this is the first I'm hearing that
his name was husky I always read it I
mean we made the script when it was when
we were doing workaholics oh you always
knew the way reading Dredd I couldn't
get a bigger part I couldn't be top I
couldn't be an FBI agent told me the guy
you totally could have been a cop but I
saved the cop
I saved the cut for the next movie am i
right oh don't try to
right okay so alright so you know you
last eaten part I didn't do it you know
I was just like you know larious by the
way you watch that in a room full of
people okay it's the most insane scene
but dude I just got off doing I'm dying
up here I don't know you laughter I
listen when when Eric when you
respectfully past yeah I understood okay
good I didn't not understand why but
then when you called again or something
you you were just like hey I might be
doing this movie I have something for
you and I was kind of like okay I wasn't
sure yeah sure enough you call and
you're like hey you got to come up and
do this movie I had something else going
on but it's like yellow Sandler wants
you to come up you know yeah cuz he was
like we well like triggers are being
pulled late on that kind of movie it's
like when do we have to pull the trigger
you know right and so it's kind of this
like balancing act of when do you show
somebody so that they don't forget
versus when does the trigger have to be
pulled and how many times am i reaching
out to Sandler for something as a bride
working with his team you know now is
this year now this was like would you
consider this like your biggest project
as a director of something oh yeah
majorly okay so this is like you you
felt like some pressure for it right
massive yeah I mean I did I tried not to
huge budget to listen to like a 60
million dollar budget something like
that was up to a hundred Wow see this is
a hundred million dollar Netflix project
it's like is Adam Sandler Jennifer
Aniston yes
yes honestly the whole time I'm like
what am I doing here but I think that's
a good thing yeah you know cuz they cut
myself in check yeah I where it's like
I'm not just going off and I'm the one
I'm not being a pretentious [ __ ] you
know what I feel like I have or I have
I've like earned that somehow yeah it's
not sure how yet but you like you know
you know what let's lead up to the
murder mystery by going backwards you
know yeah sure let's go backwards like
you know you start because I had Blake
on you know and you guys are childhood
friends right oh yeah oh you guys go way
back
you know making videos in the in the
backyard you know you guys weren't
wrestling and playing sports you guys
were like making films we did have a
wrestling show yeah like it was like WWF
yeah but you always do you wanted to do
the arts you wanted to make film did you
always want to be a director um I always
wanted to make stuff I was reluctant to
admit that I wanted to be a director
even in I mean I even directed in film
school but after film school I was still
like I just want to be an editor I just
want to be free and then I was like I
just want to be a grip why is this want
to be a key grip so lot you know I held
director up I'm like oh is it like some
insecurities or you think to yourself
J's director honestly dude I think I
just respected it and I knew that there
was a reason that it should be respected
because it's the first name that comes
up at the end of the credits or at the
beginning of the credits you know yeah
yeah it's like directed by created by
right so it's like okay that guy holds
or that that person holds all the
pressure must you know what I mean so I
didn't really want to do it but I was
doing it yeah and then I was just doing
it funny part I was doing it you
probably didn't realize that the things
you were already doing with the same
things of like what the professionals
are doing kind of it was like oh but I
insert myself into the place where a
director is I'm always there okay so you
guys are up in the Bay Area you'reyou're
doing this stuff you're doing you're
like you're doing the sketches you're
doing the the wrestling show you're
doing you know you're filming we did
improv to we we went to a public school
system that had a killer arts program
and so we were like I was definitely in
it was like Glee you guys were there
yeah but we still performed in a
multi-use room the climate of the school
it was just cool to be artistic at the
school it was accepted hmm and so like
we really ran amok in in it and I don't
know if it was just us our energy that
like kind of made it be like special but
it was like we worked hard there was a
group of us that are still actually now
on transplants down in Los Angeles right
that are still kind of like resonating
and like emitting this energy and it's
cool it very much is simple Inc was yeah
Blake and I it was one of Mike and I we
met in third grade and we made yeah so
then at that point you're in high school
you're doing all that and you decided at
that point I'm gonna go to school
right for pretty much go to a four-year
I was trapped between a four-year and
not going to college and then my mom
found a one-year program in Los Angeles
and I was like okay I'm doing that
that's what I'm gonna do cuz I want to
get in get out
it was immersive I was able to learn
everything I never left the school it
was 24 hours a day oh wow and I was just
grinding grinding grinding now while you
were there was that when you guys now
mail order comedy had already been
started you got no no this is much
before that a way before that a way
before this is about this is right after
I met Devine because Blake and I moved
from from the Bay Area down to Orange
County okay and Adam had moved to Orange
County from Omaha we met at junior
college oh yeah Wow yeah no were you
doing the art stuff in the junior
college also that was just a manager at
van shoes humble beginnings yeah it was
like a third manager at band shoot oh
you weren't even the manager made our 19
years old trying to buy like just trying
to live for the day and get wasted every
night you know like me and my buddy
lived together and then Blake would
always come over and he basically lived
there and then we would just party we
have the college life without the
college yeah and then I got into trouble
and then my mom's like hey you know you
should go to film school like oh yeah
yeah yeah went to the year so you went
to the year-long program
yeah I did that and then you after that
you got out of that and then you were
working at the store you were trying to
figure out what you wanted to do with
yourself
right I was working on sets I did the
whole like independent film got you got
rip grind like it's like pushing dolly
for like 50 bucks a day or something
like that you know you were learning
learning and the art went to that old
school then Devine and I moved in
together
boom and we started I dusted off the
camera and I was like okay we started
filming some [ __ ] you know we started
because I had an edit Bay I'd gone to
school so I knew how to edit and I had
spent the money on an avid and it was in
my room and I was always trying to
hustle and do the Craigslist thing with
that as well oh well that was like so
you had an ad like duty to movie at it
is my few what's your wedding video do
you we do an essay I'd start I did
wedding videos with my brother we did
like six weddings in our past when we
were teenagers oh yeah
people said what if those were on ebay
now edited by some of them are very very
bad I had to do one but I want to know I
want to know this were you trying to be
super artsy with the with the wedding
video oh hell yeah dude we were usually
like transitions like food my brother
and I came up with this idea we're gonna
have the bride spin around and we're
gonna play in slow motion okay but
before she got dressed the same spot
after she got dressed oh you were doing
a Wonder Woman like we just did a
transition and it's like she's all
beautiful now and people in Walnut Creek
loved it like that's bad I was a
hometown that was her calling card that
was like all right so all right so now
I'm following along you and Adam are
living together you dust off the camera
you're editing and then at that point
you guys decided why don't we film some
yeah some sketches yep we were we were
like starting to think about it a lot
like shooting more and more and kind of
like what is this what's going on
YouTube was kind of coming out at the
same time Adam was doing classes all
around Hollywood and one of them was a
second city in Los Angeles class oh wow
and he met onder's there oh that's where
they clicked up this is the
yeah and then they totally dude and then
Adam introduced me to Anders which
resulted in a drunken fight the first
night I'm not surprised ya know it was
crazy but then resulted in us going Adam
wanting to bridge their relationship so
he invited us to go see Kung Fu Hustle
the next day oh wow and so we hung full
hustle saved your relationship with all
like I'm here today because of Kung Fu
Hustle is that what you're saying yeah
yeah exactly dude exactly like we bonded
over it it was like that movie was so
tight and visually it was radical and
and it was like okay cool now let's be
friends and then we were friends and
then it was like we started and he was a
writer so he we started writing and it
was actually perfect you had Blake and
Adam as these kind of wacky performers
you were behind the camera handling it
all I knew how to do that Andres is like
the adult in the group you know of those
guys grounding our grounding element now
been a perfect storm for mail order
comedy yeah yeah and we were playing in
these big sketch worlds like
high-concept
you know like crossbows and moustache
there's all these colorful worlds and
all that stuff and doing different
textures and playing and seeing what we
could figure what we could do with just
the four of us plus some of my friends
from film school you know like what what
could we do with like a skeleton crew
this [ __ ] is funny like these guys are
highly entertaining yeah they sure are
and I was cutting everything to sew I
was editing at all and so I was in the
lab but just like yeah yeah like going
insane and it just clicked right you
just fell into place yeah the the
language that they were speaking
on-screen it was a coincided with your
your language and then you guys just
created this thing yeah cuz we were all
friends you know we were friends and
then it became we flipped it into the
business and it was like it worked
because we had the shorthand of
friendship I was gonna say it's like an
authentic relationship you know that's
the one thing I always look back on
workaholics some of my favorite episodes
there's just nothing big going on it's
just
it's just them doing what they do you
know the this just like natural
chemistry that the three of them have
with each other oh yeah then with you at
the helm well that's I mean honestly
it's because it's like we can run
microphones that can capture everybody
and we don't have to be so structured
within how we create stuff anymore that
we are allowed to capture that type of
relationship also so when women when it
was time for workaholics and you guys
you you were ready to create it on your
own is that isn't that right isn't it
like you guys you guys made to pilot
yourself in a sense yeah the original
pilot the original pilot which was all
they so basically we were doing all that
stuff the thing that hit was our most
low concept workaholics you know what I
mean like we had [ __ ] rapid Wizards
it was just like so up there they're
like you know what give us the office
comedies out that one the more recent
owners in an office we like that one
which is why we have a whole bunch of
episodes that push the envelope because
we want to do that high-concept crazy
[ __ ] but the thing that was the most
relatable was just the most low concept
[ __ ] we could think of dudes and a house
dudes in the office speaking our
language yeah you know yeah yeah I
remember when I first read the script
for workaholics for the audition I
remember reading that just thinking oh
this is never gonna get on the air like
I thought to myself are they really
gonna let someone save these particular
things on TV I had no idea like even in
the pilot like the first joke this is in
the presentation as well as the whole
like order of how you should do a dick
pic how it goes nipple dick [ __ ]
butthole and we're just like there's no
way we can do this we can say nipple
dick [ __ ] butthole a few times yeah in
an episode right [ __ ] yeah but we
wanted to push that so they were like
Comedy Central ultimately saw it and was
like hey shout out to Walter Newman who
saw it he's the best amazing man and
then they said here's a pilot
presentation here's 50 grand to go make
a pilot presentation and I didn't
understand what that was
but you were ready I was ready but the
pilot presentation was like 10 minutes
or 8 to 10 minutes of what the show
could be and so I was like this is wack
so what did you do we shot a whole
episode we shot an entire episode and
the quality didn't go down right quality
went up because of it and then so you
know what you did though you screwed
yourself well I screwed one
yeah you're screwed yeah cause you use
good people because they work we've got
yes cuz they know cuz because the studio
went like this
oh [ __ ] so we can make a whole show for
50,000 yeah well and then everybody
afterwards was trying to make these
pilot presentation shows for 50 green
rise super hard to pull off yeah yeah
yeah I had all these connections with
you owned the camera yeah we had you had
all your buddies you had a support
system in place I went back ten years
yep so these guys that thought like oh
we can do this on our garage just like
to do some workaholics did it's like a
lack of respect for your guy what you
guys brought to the table I mean really
what I did is I littered it with like I
think it's like 150 grand worth of music
in it and so they heard that I placed it
well and yeah Blake gave me a CD of like
of the tracks he's like try and put
these ones in I'm like okay and then we
just boom yeah actually we're gonna air
it you know but now you just turn to
$50,000 show into it you know two and a
half million yeah then but they saw that
and they're like okay cuz I always
figure like we were like when we talked
about it be like let's just give them
one of the episodes in the DVD set
mm-hmm
you know like we're not even really
starting or stop or like making a
conscious decision to start these
characters we're just in the world yeah
and then they saw that and from the
presentation they grabbed ten Wow yeah I
remember my first ever well I remember
the audition yeah we had to cast it I
said we need to round it out yeah I
needed more characters we had the three
guys in coral yeah and Alice and Jillian
yeah you did we get a different Alice we
had a different outfit I remember that
yeah that was super weird yeah
because you actually you had to remake
the pilot you made the pilot right I
guess yeah we had to cuz there was art
all over the wall stuff like monster
posters and [ __ ] from the house cuz we
shot in the house that we lived in so I
was like you know all that [ __ ] wasn't
cleared so then you alright and then you
made it and then I guess are you casting
and I'm like I said I remember walking
in the room after the original call like
I remember the original I really wanted
that part like I remember I know you
working on it with my honey and then so
I went to the original you know their
first cat first call and wuzzlewood app
with Alison Alyssa I mean oh yeah Alyssa
right listen wise Bert and then like
I'll never forget when I finished doing
it she looked at her partner and they
looked at each other and she went okay
you know cuz I don't think anybody did
it the way I did it right you know and
then I went to the first card one no no
this was a character that we were so
excited about to see Anna he would know
the backstory all man Montez was like I
think Montez is somebody's onder's no
slackers ya know somebody named Dante's
in Chicago and he would do this cool
impression that just had us all in
stitches and like so we knew we just
wanted to go with like somebody who was
a nerd but also could speak the could
speak the slang you know compete it
could use a little urban but you're not
sure little bit and like yeah exactly
and also mold in some dad jokes just
some some dumb comedy in there too which
is not great and we were stoked and then
you came a day early
yeah I was talking about that's how much
she wanted this you came a day early I
know cuz Blake was like he was taking a
leak or something I was like hey man he
was like you must be here for Montez
right he's like that's tomorrow
dude he came back in the room and was
like I think I just saw Montez is this
agree but again I remember walking in
the room and a lot of people came in and
auditioned for months oh yeah it was
dude - do I know all these people it was
like and then another thing - about it
you didn't know what you wanted
there was Latino guys right it was black
guys it was like it was they didn't know
what they wanted and I remember walking
in the room
first time and I saw all of us off first
I saw Adam and I was you know new album
right I knew him so I didn't know like I
was like oh this is cute Adams in here
like business you know the door guy from
the intern you know I had no idea and
then I never I remember this
specifically too because I was like all
the guys people I'm making jokes and
then you were like you it was like oh
I'm the director and I was like okay
well there's the most important guy in
the room I remember singing that and
then like you know doing the audition
and then I got notes the first note was
oh yeah it's too big and then that's a
note that will follow for years to come
[ __ ] yo k how about this though I come
in to do this the next time
and then then second audition and your
ass goes hey what happened what happened
what happened was I took a goddamn note
and then what you realize is you don't
like that hey it's a fickle business
yeah hey dog edition four times for the
[ __ ] part you know and then what we
did we took everybody through the ranks
because we actually had to I know who
the politic like I know it was like
that's what I've had to go in front of
like everybody live oh wow
it was alive it turn at him and I gave
her a note to like bite Adams head off
just like don't even let him finish just
like Sock'em and I think that's what
well it worked out or her I mean it
worked out and we just we end up making
a little show that could Oh for real man
that first season was unbelievable when
we were all just grinding right around
here and yeah ya know that crazy now
Studios casting taking over that top
died atop the floor yep I remember my
first scene was the I was doing the the
what was it well this thing is the same
size all right my invitation got lost in
the mail I'll have to grate up that has
a lot of great quotables from you but
that was my first it is that's my
favorite I say all the time when they
come in and like ask you for the tickets
but that was the first time too that I
was like be becoming comfortable with
like the idea that like we're improving
a little bit you know yeah you know
people always ask us like Merkel Helga's
improv and I was like no no it's very
scripted me and they figure out what
they wanted they got a Bible of things
cuz if it was all improv they would be
terrible right exactly you know exactly
so but it was it was fun I remember that
with the tickets and like all that stuff
and I was like wow this we really got
something here yeah my first first real
director yeah you know I'm your Marty
Scorsese yeah you're the first one like
you know and then by the you know by
season seven it was like you know you
know we had like two takes and it was
like moving on you know dude we had it
so dialed though was it dialed okay are
you kidding me single on a doe single a
double yes then you turn around on me
and Bill you got you're single don't you
worry bill might and I got the single
okay got your single don't worry bill
and I you just have we reached out bets
going on the over-under on how many
takes it would take to it it was always
like two and a half was the over-under
that's pretty good two and a half yeah
that would be the one where I just speed
through I'm like I just see that one
line that's it all right
try saying this there we got it we got
it jokes are good no my favorite thing
my favorite story about you also is like
you calling me so I'm doing them I do
them dying up here
you know you know and then you kill you
hit me up you're like yo man you've
really grown as a performer oh yeah yeah
but my thought was I'm shooting these
shows at the same time I didn't go to
acting class for two years and they'd
come do that no no they were being shot
at the same time remember you coming in
to set like 20/20 hindsight into
workaholics at being like who ma'am
Melissa Leo whoa whoa whoa and I'm like
I think that just like bounced off I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about am i I'm trying to [ __ ] run a
show over here if you care about and
that [ __ ] was chaos by the way the final
season oh dude yeah it just was like it
was didn't it was insane but I remember
you then when I watched the show I'm
like hell yeah dude this guy was taking
some trips
work on ya colleagues like I'm saying
like we knew everybody's comedic angle
and where they would come in and that's
why we stopped it
you know we had [ __ ] around with it so
much we had made ders the crazy one we
made Blake the straight one we've tried
to contain Adam yeah but Adam ended up
work you know it was like it's like we
just made you feel like it ran its
course we knew it without like
completely recycling it it's like what
else are we gonna do what other drug can
we take none of us have even taken
[ __ ] peyote but we're like saying
it's cool yeah like if comi central guys
still be doing it today I mean [ __ ] yeah
we really had ran at the course and
we've done all we can do I said it's a
fickle business so from workaholics you
know workaholics ended but you were
doing a lot of other stuff that you you
directed a bunch of community episodes
right yeah and stuff like that and you
know yeah and then you you guys went
into a game over me yeah yeah yeah that
was game over man your first feature
film directing yeah well yes exactly
yeah well to do film it was totally that
was when I went into it for the first
time and it wasn't that one was it felt
like in bigger
we just finished workaholic so it was
workaholics movie it was yeah you know
it was like they do though it's gonna be
a workaholics whatever but that one was
crazy just because he didn't work for
Comedy Central anymore right right all
of a sudden we were working for big red
yeah you know no but weird times I asked
Blake about this it's like do you think
that because of the times the political
times and the sensitivity and and me to
that like game over man like say would
it have been even larger say five years
ago but because of like because it's
such a such a guy
you know girls with tits out and like
that it's such a guys centric type of
thing ours isn't guys girls with tits
out ours is a guys with dicks out
you dick out man [ __ ] but you know I'm
just saying indeed I mean do you think
that like like it's like is there a
sequel in the works to me do you think
like you would have made three for those
type of movies if it was different times
you thought politics have me now to do
with that I think so I think that like
you know we went out there with our
middle fingers up and we're just kind of
like this is what we're doing yeah you
blew dogs up and had people a see yeah
cut dicks off through dicks across the
room exploded heads glorified violence
like man you know but that it's a weird
win like the like that we were
entertainment so we were supposed to be
the escape right but then when you
become conscious of the outside world
and the outside world is like kind of
being the absurdist yeah and a weird
wacky like it feels like absurdism is
all around us like nobody's got their
heads on straight
now the sudden the reason why I came to
Hollywood which is to get that [ __ ] out
yeah is not acceptable and all now it's
up to me to like wait do I have to
assume you have to police yourself I
have to assume a very responsible we're
all right now
yeah which is just not entertainment and
if that's the weird thing about it that
people forgot weird but I I mean I look
at workaholics and I'm like I'm sorry
game over man and I'm like I'm still
okay with it yeah no problem with it
when my son's a certain age he'll see it
yeah yeah yeah and we'll look at it yeah
I'll be like look this is what was going
on are you ready for this kids right
turns like what like 15 yeah 15 I mean I
don't know I don't know how much I'll
wait I will see yeah but I didn't
imagine what the technology will be by
then you know people be like look at
your dad like when Donald Trump [ __ ]
robot in the middle of Central Park
and live games and on Instagram you know
resident and it's like we can't impeach
because of these rules you know what you
what a great moment I also remember from
workaholics is that time you had to get
your hair cut
Oh for the bowl cut yeah for the bowl
cut and you know that was slow sensitive
about your hair at the time yeah you
were just like a wad you out you know
you always were more sensitive than I
realized yeah that was like you know I'm
a comic I'm I remember the day that you
like we're like hey man it was like you
had like a tide he was a mr. tie-dye
shirts and whatever and I was teasing
you a little bit and I saw in your face
I was like oh he really is dude
sometimes I am yeah for sure I mean
comedy is cool and all and I like that
but also at that time when we were
making workaholics it was like I
probably was getting ribbed on by
everybody else and then I saw you and
I'm like you're just kind of sensitive
to right for a second you know what I
thought then I was like you know what I
stopped after that yeah cuz it's like I
knew that you could maybe stop it where
everybody else we were so in the [ __ ]
tornado of yeah comedy that it was like
now you got your now you got your sea
legs during workaholics yeah you doing
community yeah you felt you felt you
know and you pitch in studio films and
you know you have valuable reads and
you're ready to go and then you get this
opportunity to do this Sandler movie now
how did that even come about oh man that
was like I go to all these meetings
right we are they find a script that I
like and they like me for and I'll go to
the meeting and we'll talk about it and
probably 90% of the time that movie
doesn't get made it's just not moving
you know those were the types of
meetings that I was kind of hidden or
it's like I'm responsible for developing
this stuff so I read murder mystery and
I was like this is dope like it's a it's
a very self-aware obviously from the
title it's a very self-aware comedic
genre comedy you know what I mean like
murder mystery comedy and it's like they
have Sandler and Jennifer Aniston who
they were attached from jump yeah like
when I read the script the first time I
was reading for Sandler and I was
reading I think I was reading for
Aniston mm-hmm you know and I made the
final call it was with Sandler did he
make the call would he feel like I want
this guy
direct yeah I mean I think like what
happened was I think there was a little
back-and-forth with another director and
then ultimately they were like no we're
going with the new dude because
Sandler's like I want to go with the
with the new fresh voice mm-hmm I want
the I want the freshest and he had just
come off of his his uh comedy his comedy
special for Netflix right which he had
been shooting for two years Jesus and so
he he was looking at two years worth of
stand-up material and putting it
together as I was prepping this and I'm
like oh he's in a reinvention phase
right now yeah which is cool so then
okay so now we're caught up to when
you're telling you you kind of knew you
were gonna do the movie so you had an
idea that last part was like maybe Eric
can do this part but that movie that I
don't know how it happen it just clicked
and they they called me they said you
got it films and Italy it films and
Montreal films and Monte Carlo and I'm
just like oh yeah I went to the Netflix
I went to the meeting with Netflix and
thinking like man no way no way no
[ __ ] way I'm not going this movie but
I went in there with like a hard stance
and I was like what I want to do is not
put comedians around for the majority of
it I don't want to put comedians around
Jenn and Adam I don't want them fighting
to be funny right right right
make sense that was what I didn't want
to have happen in the dynamic of the
movie I wanted there to be a murder
mystery that was taken very seriously
and it was like you know it's its own
thing
true to the genre and then I have these
two buffoons in the center of it you
know like they get trapped in it and
they're allowed to comment on it because
they're aware of the genre I was like I
have to build a proper genre around them
sweet yeah genre comedies you have to
build the genre yeah if you don't build
the genre you [ __ ] you're not doing
it I I was doing this other I was doing
like this artsy film at the time and I'd
already committed to it you know then
you call me and again I had that thought
in my head from
yeah we're gonna get my ass eating again
no no I God and you're like I'm by the
way you like I'll do this is Sandler
moving I was like okay you like you know
you know I was like well I don't know I
don't I just if I commit to something I
want to do it I did you know I go back
on my word on these you know even though
it was like a smaller movie yeah but
then you call me back you like look man
Sandler wants you we got to make this
work you know what because he was like
he's like what about your boy for for
Jimmy there's always like what's up with
Jimmy yeah I'm like we lost he's on
another thing we didn't move fast enough
and I'm not this movie is the first
thing that I didn't produce I'm just a
director on it okay which is which is
it's still a very very huge role I was
able to detach myself there was enough
people that can deal with that something
said they should that should be handled
mm-hm and so Eric Griffin was said it
was stated like a couple weeks before
and Sandler was in uh and then I was
like yo this is serious we got to go cuz
I knew you had that other yeah yeah yeah
and then that what that was one of the
only times I got a call from Sandler to
is he's like what happened to Jimmy
happened to Jimmy I'm like dude we just
I said it I said it [ __ ] weeks ago
I'm in this you call me like it was like
we hear from you and then then you you
know you hit me up like yo man this is
like in a couple days and I'm like bro I
can't just drop everything I'm doing wha
do but it worked out and I mean I was in
the middle of a tornado
I was flights from LA to montreal
montreal to France France Drive to Italy
and then back to LA and then I did that
again two more times I did that three
times and then I started shooting
okay so then like this is in three this
is like in two and a half months I did
that three times so I got to uh sorry I
came up and that was the first day of
shooting right you were you you were the
first person a shooting so worst day of
shooting I needed Eric Griffin on set so
one thing I noticed is we had this
little run-through you know and I'm
seeing you and I'm like that was the
first time I was like oh this is a big
[ __ ] deal
I was like this is a big [ __ ] deal
and I can tell I can honestly tell that
it was like you and already whatever
your prep but now was real and I could
tell you a little nervous oh dude I can
tell you a little nervous you you know
what I knew - this is a great moment cuz
like okay so now Sandler now I meet
Sandler right yeah the next day I hehe
and I'm like you know I'm like whoa this
is like this is real you know I mean
we're doing this like I hadn't met him
yet actually he didn't come to the it
was like we were doing with the stunt
guy we were figuring out all the things
he wanted to do
oh yeah right and then what you didn't
realize is you said to me you said hey
guy go this you're going to this dinner
you're like everyone is dinner and I'll
see you tomorrow you know and then I get
a call from you get over to this dinner
yeah cuz again we were at dinner and
like I didn't know I didn't set the
[ __ ] dinner I know I know a producer
I got your guest yeah then you don't
notice you know I noticed there's a
chair open I was like go samory you want
me to call Eric he's like call call
Jimmy and it was great I remember I
walked in late and I was like it was one
of those things where I was late and
like the whole room like turned you know
I mean the whole room was like ooh you
know yeah I was like oh and then I'm
looking and I'm like [ __ ]
it's Sandler Jennifer Aniston the dude
from Beauty and the Beast oh you know
the producers the other table and then
I'm like everybody's looking at me then
I make a joke I'm like like oh my F
table or like you know so those other
guys were like how dare you you know and
then stammered you know what I
appreciated about him was like his
attention to detail about things because
when I said to him I was like us to do
for beauty to beast I was so excited he
was like hey that's just like your bit
so he had seen my stand-up right and was
referencing it right you know Jennifer
Aniston was nice she gives me a big hug
and I'm thinking to myself oh my god I'm
on friends you know oh dude I mean it's
true very genuinely beautiful people yes
like beautiful souls like really awesome
people to go to battle with and make a
movie but then it was all business time
so then the next day oh yeah man when
you're doing it when you're grinding on
set you know you're at the center of
you're at the
tip of the spear and you're cutting
through and so nervous to [ __ ] has to be
said if you're feeling it and if you're
not feeling it
if you're feeling something you have to
say it that's how it works at the center
of that movie said you know but was that
the first time also you of course you
talked to him and you planned things
with him but this is the first time now
you're on set with him too is the same
time I was there right is that right
yeah pretty much
yeah so yeah and what I noticed about
him you immediately was like that's one
of the lines you know and I was like
whoa okay this is like you know and I
can tell you were just like you you were
very much like right and he you were
finding you're finding your way with him
well cuz that effort again that
particular scene exactly it was it was
day one a stunt how do we work together
yes under pressure because he is a
decision-maker major decision maker and
meticulous meticulous I remember then
his and his thoughts are great remember
though it's like I remember the guy
that's playing the robber in the store
he he looked at them and he said that's
a wig I don't know it's too Wiggy that's
right he was like this is too Wiggy I
don't know yeah that's right and then we
ended up putting some yeah yeah but I
just thought to myself I was I was
watching him I was like oh this dude is
like he's all over it like every aspect
of the whole like every part of the the
scene he has it in his head whether it
be the lighting with Sandler is cool
like that because he's done 70 movies
but he was also very giving to though
exactly he was like a control freak no
no I mean like gave you know he's the
kind of guy that and he has his own
company so he's the kind of guy that
will go to Transpo and say what's up
yeah you know what I mean yeah yes he
said is his home yeah he's and every
corner there every corner of it his
family's coming in so it's like which is
exactly the way that I came up with
workaholics this set was my home well
you know what I mean and so I think
we'll circle once we realized that we
were in that same world and we only work
for this project
and we just have to make this project as
[ __ ] great as it can be you know we
have to push some boundaries be it like
just the limits of where we can go and
what we can
I like that he always wanted to after
every take he goes and looks at the
monitor playback playback - yeah yeah I
never that's I really enjoyed that too
cuz I never really experienced that I'm
starting to get used to it because they
have it on movies and so on game over
man I had it and then on murder-mystery
I had it so I'm just kind of like it's
it's a kind of a cool way to just a look
and be like we got it you know I'm
sitting there directing a couple pros
major major pros so they both want to
come back and watch their performance
right right because if they can get it
in two we can get it in two you know
what I mean we don't have to do all this
laborious work when we're trying to like
but some of them we get it in twelve
because it's a tough moment you know I
gotta say it the next day is like so we
do that stunt thing it was fun
you know oh you know we're you know
we're then we did that great walk and
talk that was awesome you know great
that's like right at the beginning of
the movie yeah it was very much like
that was so nervous at first I was like
I'm gonna walk in talk here with Sandler
it's a tough shot and it's a tough shot
we're walking way down the street people
with babies and there's a car is coming
and we have to get the lines right it
was like you know so you know a big shot
yeah sure Montreal Street
Rob Schneider actually hit me up the
other day and he was like yo man Sandler
was talking about you because he's in
he's in middle of editing and he was
like loving this scene you guys did so I
was like I can't wait for it to come out
you know performances in the movie are
so good and that's like one thing that
was super cool working as just the
director is I didn't have all this I
mean the movie's a logistical nightmare
across three khans oh yeah you know what
I mean three countries and it's just I
still have said Jimmy didn't make it to
Italy like Oh me in the sequel but then
I was able to just be like performance
yeah yeah you know like let's just talk
about where you're coming from that
didn't ring true for me so it's like I
feel like I got some of the dopest
performances in this movie well I'm
excited I were to come out I you know
and in that I'm sure this will lead to
like bigger and better things for you
right like what's what's your dream
project
I don't know man I just want to make
what I feel you know I think it'd be
cool to be able to just pick a project
and be like I want this and I want to do
it now you know what I mean
have you what's uh I talk about movies a
lot on here tunas like what saying we
always talk about going to a movie but
then you get so busy and now you have a
baby like you know oh yeah yeah I know
like what what do you watch that's all
I'm doing now is watching
I just watched I watched I watched some
TV I got back into some binge watching
Oh marvellous miss Mazal how did you
like that yeah I thought season season 1
I hit it hard
season 2 I'm like why you in France what
the [ __ ] is going on right now what
happened a little salty I'm a little
salty about this show because that's
like you know you know our show didn't
get the same kind of love but it is what
it is that's the last that's actually
the last like show i binge twas your
show watch a [ __ ] i don't want your
[ __ ] TV yeah yeah you're not a TV guy
I'm dying up here I loved it I loved it
season one people so juiced season two
fell off a little bit oh you didn't like
see I've liked side blow no that's when
I started like making I don't know where
help and I Ness why we got canceled
CDs totally your fault [ __ ]
aside about that but movies I loved bird
box
did you I thought it was weird yeah I
thought it was really good but I guess
that's what I was good about it it was
like a wall but I just that's the kind
of movie though that I was like there
you you can't it's kind of like lost the
TV show Lost where you don't really want
to know what it is well you can't really
show him here's what's really happening
cuz you're gonna be like ass
anti-climactic so in this movie like you
don't really like they never say like
are these demons are these like is it
you just kind of go okay what do they
how they gonna survive in this little
bird sanctuary yes you can I don't wanna
know like they're not gonna survive
enough they laid enough enough bread
crumbs to be like okay they will be safe
here the living conditions are gonna
suck because it's like 200 people this
is the end yeah where do they [ __ ] oh
man and then what and she didn't even
tell her like they didn't even give her
the rules like hey if the birds start
going crazy everybody close your eyes
think it was no
right you know how do you yeah yeah
there was no way they should have had
like so like that a little like welcome
to the sanctuary rule number one you
know that's that's bird box too that's
how they open it I I enjoyed it no I
thought it was it's completely divisive
you know it like just devices in
everything you can't [ __ ] see yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] I know these rules that
they're making up but I didn't mind it I
thought it was hella creative yeah what
I thought it was created for the sake of
being creative like if somebody was like
hey let's here's what we'll do here we
are
alright yeah well what's I enjoyed it I
had a good visceral watch yeah me too I
thought you know this is what I liked
about Netflix I liked that you could
just like you don't have to like do this
chore of like getting in your car and
picking the type of movie you want to
see in a theater thinking about this
money you're gonna waste and like is
this gonna be worth it so you can kind
of just be like you know what I'm gonna
check out oh yeah this one and this time
of year screeners I mean I'm getting I
got I got all the screeners I got
everything yeah I didn't pay my dues in
time so oh my god what see you because
I'm not working right now dude I have to
DJ they'll come get me oh well you cuz
you're working constantly that's a
stronger union they'll come get me but I
had a white guys mad like 70 screeners
at the crib right now it's unbelievable
right you're on an island I don't know
okay you know you're gonna be on an
island you're gonna be for six months
what's the five movies you have to have
with you for your downtime movies yeah
are there move are you a movie person
like is it like here's my movie like
this is my movie for me it's the
Godfather like I wouldn't need one and
two would be part of my thing those are
great I would buy that I'm want the
matrix
I'd grab I'm okay in School of Rock and
that's funny yeah those would be like
those are like oh that's a great movie
yeah I can watch School of Rock like any
time of day I did I just can't just put
it on I think I would grab the labyrinth
of course just because I need it just
because I needed it's in my soul really
okay yeah that shit's cool I just
started messing with puppets it's
you're gonna see that's not weird at all
a whole different side of me soon my
friend you coming out with your puppet
movie that was gonna be the next I got
puppet music video coming out pretty
cool okay so you get the Lambert's okay
okay yeah the labyrinth ah see I want to
pull a ninja turtles into it too I'll
see you just okay you're you you're
always gonna your your side are you
sci-fi you just no no Ninja Turtle is
like maybe the first one but that's just
inferred nostalgic I think that's for
but a lot of my core values came from
there two of brotherhood and friendship
what I like about what you're saying
right now is that because I find that
people that are like let's say you're a
sound person right you can't watch a
movie without a guy this sound sucks
I can feel a lighting person you're like
every time you lie they light it like
that mm-hmm no as a director do you find
yourself having trouble sometimes
watching things if you go like why do
they make that [ __ ] choice oh yeah so
is this why then when you're thinking
about the movies that you like it's kind
of mindless kind of just like you know
these are just fun I can you could
divorce yourself of that process I love
entertainment for entertainment that's
good I don't don't ever lose that yeah
that's my favorite thing like I think I
would bring I guess I'd bring diehard
IKEA I mean I kind of have to it's tough
because it's either die hard or we the
weapon yeah well I think it's die hard
just because it's in the genre I would
say I would eat the weapons a better
movie almost man he thinks so better
dynamic we got the back and forth
between I respect the dynamic more I
think we I think I like that's why I'm a
guy like man I like that character my
man is basically we find up an inside of
die hard but three men and a baby
uh yeah I think if I had to pick to it
like who would you want in a sticky
situation you wanna you wanna murder
Murtaugh is that what doesn't have
lieutenant Murtagh Murtagh or do you
want Riggs
Riggs want Riggs yeah you want Riggs
it's like okay do you want Jack Reacher
or do you want John wick John wick
just [ __ ] bad but Jack Reacher
actually I have a fight with my friends
all the time that I think they're the
same I think Jack Reacher and John wick
gotta say it should move e John wick is
just so much more violent no I think
well that means that they're not the
same right
or just John wick has more bad guys
getting right I think they did yeah well
at the end of the first the second Jack
Reacher was just horrendous the count
just took the first one we trick but the
second John wick was great but I'm just
saying like if the if John wick and Jack
Reacher were were going up again if they
were adversaries who would you go with
who you got your money on I mean I think
that Keanu is I'm going Keanu now it's
not do this because I would think to say
that you like it's like oh you're gonna
go with the Scientologist are you gonna
go with them and you can't do that it's
John wick and Jack Reacher yeah well I
didn't even hunch by the way I think
John wick is more capable I think he has
more tricks he thinks our physical trip
you think he's more bestia Jack Reacher
is more of a my a little bit more of a
mind
he was pretty vomiting into that first
one okay okay then alright so we go in
John wick if we're doing our if we're
doing brackets but then then where's
Ethan Hunt do you take Ethan Hunt over
John wick whoa yeah because he has more
access is more he's got more toys
exactly yeah I think I think I would
take Ethan Hunt over Jack Reacher's yeah
and that's more entertainment than
violence also if you're just going from
movies like I remember Mission
Impossible as being more critical
thinking movies than John wick is and I
think I appreciate a good critical
thinking movie or at least a plotline
that makes me think but if you can make
them all rated R which I think what they
should be sure I think if the you know
that's the problem would I believe it's
like it's like when you first all Logan
Logan was crazy when you when I first
saw Logan and I saw those claws go
through that guy's head and to begin the
movie I thought oh [ __ ] yeah this is why
they haven't ever shown this because
that is gruesome you know like it's like
that's what that really would look like
right you know but we kind of like we've
kind of like we haven't filled that in
in our head
right so now right now we're filling
that in and we're like oh I don't know
if I like this but I wonder what that I
mean you know just stepping out
culturally I wonder what as the as the
industry becomes more and more graphic
you know like Hollywood or entertainment
industry the world seems to be coming
more and more graphic so back to what
I'm saying is I wonder if Hollywood's
gonna actually become a little bit more
prude and it's like it's gonna rain it
rain it in a little bit you know like
Disney kind of isolating itself in a
very like good area you know I just
wonder I wonder I don't know what think
it goes in cycles depending on what's
also going on in society I mean I think
when you look back to like the Clinton
era with the Monica Lewinsky and like
people having to talk about [ __ ]
with their kids right all these kind of
things and then Something About Mary was
out at the particular time and like you
know it's like yeah I think that was
like I think that there was some
subconsciously there was something
connecting there so I think whatever
it's going on like when we're feeling
more prude in society then then then the
movies are gonna be like okay we're not
gonna show blood we're not gonna show
violence we're gonna like it just got
then it it's seesaws goes the other way
and then you pull it back a little bit
yeah that's why I like you know Mary
Poppins is doing well or whatever like
that's coming back because you need that
type of entertainment I'm glad we have a
lot of options though like yeah yeah if
I want to go see Mary Poppins fine but I
also want to go see John wick blow
somebody's head off of course you got to
have all those outlets you got to have
them all but Mary Poppins was like an
integral piece of film that like shaped
my childhood when I was a kid you know
loved it yeah and it was in my head that
was shaped on spoonful of sugar so it's
I so would you want to direct Mary
Poppins or John wick you had a choice
they came I don't need to Mary Poppins
to or John wick three go I would do I'd
probably do Mary Poppins to I yeah I
just knew you were gonna say that I
probably would cuz I mean like John wick
3 yes
that's dope but I would need to put
comedy in there I would have to put
comedy okay Blake and I were gonna do a
comedy that was gonna be basically like
John wick like comedy yeah I better be a
villain or something in that if it gets
me Oh
you would have been you would have you
would have had a part also they can't
are you not doing it no see they
actually said they wouldn't do this it
was an ultra violent kind of like this
is the kind of day and age with like
they said no we had to set up at Netflix
and then Netflix is like we're not gonna
do this right now it's just not gonna
happen and then that's actually when I
I'd scouted it and I found the place in
Atlanta and then that's when they were
like Netflix was like actually we're not
doing sex castle but we are doing murder
mystery and you'll be perfect for that
because if your work on came over man
and I'm like there you go
see that that's how it's like you stuck
to like what you but it was such a weird
feeling because I was about to do this
crazy awesome project with Blake yeah
you know guy who I was making comic
books with and you've known since you
were in the third grade yeah and we were
about to have the keys and the Netflix
does some insider trading and it's like
you're not doing that you're not doing
that you're doing that Wow
I mean nothing but love for Netflix they
they're the dopest it was just weird
feeling you know well then hey obviously
it all worked out because here you are
you know you just got off this great
project you have a good relationship
with Sandler I mean that's a great I'm
still I'm still figures crossed he's
like hey let's get other guy to play
Jimmy again for this other thing you
know yeah bro
you'll be back Oh knock on wood right
what listen man I think what I think
we're at like an hour right no so you
look at that see well would you look at
that the mustache crew right yeah
totally ma'am yeah well you have a new
baby and do how's that house being a
father is it is it changed your
perspective on on like what you do or is
it like your focus like what are you
know what are all the cliches that
people say about having a kid are you
what are you excited about it was
interesting because like you know go
from game over man a super
boundary-pushing who gives a [ __ ] kind
of attitude it to a Sandler movie that
is a little bit more broader you've got
to have the whole family sitting down to
watch this one and the whole time I was
making it like my wife was pregnant yeah
yeah so yeah my palate shifted a little
bit like I think I still I will always
be like into what
where the dirt is right now like let me
see it but I'm just going awful but I
think I'm growing a I'm not sipping as
much haterade on on the broad stuff you
know I think I used to sip a lot of area
on like this [ __ ] that's like it's fine
what do you mean because it has good
values and stuff it's my it's bad no I
kind of want that [ __ ] to go into my
son's brain too
you know you look a look at that look so
yeah you look at you all grown up that's
what I'm saying man I came here as an
absurdist and now I am a responsible
[ __ ] insane well with that I think
that's a good stopping point man I'm
really glad that you came on I want to
have you on again another time you know
you're always welcome to to come in and
will you shoot the [ __ ] about stuff and
hopefully we'll get to work together
again like you've been all my major at
all my major points in my career right
now so I you know my first TV show yeah
I first made your movie oh yeah so now
we got to get one that on the big screen
I do one will have to do one will have
to do one closer to the premiere like
when we're getting yeah yeah yeah for
sure right afterwards or something we
just kidnapped Sandler and could get him
in here yeah for sure
oh well anyways guys I want to thank
Carla check for coming on my bloody
first director ever and I want to thank
everybody for continuing to watch
riffing with Griffin this is Eric
Griffin
signing off and I will see you guys next
week
[Music]